I want you to do whatever you have to do
for you to go feel alive short of
violate your marriage vows because right
now he sees his wife is frustrated and
devastated and his body is blaming him
yet
again and so the greatest gift you can
give him is to begin to stand tall and
you go work out if that's what you want
to
do you go hang out with your girlfriends
if that's what you want to do hey I want
to go see my mom and dad I just can't
all right great man we're GNA have a
blast
mm and let me tell you my wife did that
three or four
times and then I came around to my kids
and my wife and my in-laws are making
memories and I'm not a part of I'm not
in any of these
photos I have to
change I've got to change because I want
to be a part of their
life and it was seeing light